okay let's talk a little bit about
geopolitics and
and alliances all right we live in a
world of countries that's how the planet
is organized for the most part we can
disagree
with the concept of nation states there
are anarchists who do there are others
who do uh we could argue that nation
states have been a negative influence on
human well-being but we could that
that's a debate that we could have
right now nation-states exist and they
are one of the most influential types of
administrative body
that affects the lives of the nearly 8
billion people on earth so the point is
relationships between nation states are
of huge importance
period some of the largest damage that
donald trump has done
some of the most difficult to undo
damage that donald trump has done
is to our relationships with our
historical allies uh
alienating us from many of our
historical
western democratic allies and instead
sucking up and brown-nosing more and
more to the authoritarians
and the brutal dictators and this ranges
from you know going from memory you've
got kim jong-un in north korea
turkey's erdogan yair bolsonaro in
brazil vladimir putin and russia of
course
president xi in china rodrigo duterte in
the philippines there might be others
that i'm forgetting
british prime minister theresa may has
now straight up
condemned donald trump as i've already
covered
donald trump made these xenophobic
tweets over the weekend directed at
freshman members of congress such as
alexandria ocasio-cortez and others
suggesting they go back to
their countries their countries of
course being the united states
typical red meat right-wing xenophobia
uh meant to distract from the endless
trump scandals that are going on i
already talked about
that the widespread condemnation from
the american left
but now theresa may is jumping into the
fray is certainly no bleeding heart
liberal to say the least and in a
statement her official spokesman said
quote
the prime minister's view is that the
language
used to refer to these women was
completely unacceptable period
full stop okay this is not language
that the leaders of our major allies
tend to use
about the president of the united states
and this is again forging new ground
in this rapid decline that donald trump
has been able to catalyze in our
relationships with our historical allies
and once again
i know that the trump is right and much
of the broader american right
doesn't give two you-know-whats about
this some europeans don't like trump
good screw them because trump is doing
stuff that's good for us
not what's good for them and i support
trump make america great again i'm going
to order 10 more of those stupid red
hats
now there is a fair criticism to make
here which is that
very easy and convenient for theresa may
to say this now
she's on her way out it's very easy for
her now to say this
since it doesn't matter what the
political consequences are of directly
condemning
the statements of an american president
she's going to be gone soon and that's
true
but that actually should be a warning to
us okay
there are likely many more leaders of
our allies that are
thinking the same things as theresa may
that are seeing what donald trump says
and does
and their sincerely held belief is one
of wanting to condemn it
but they're not doing it because they've
got to work with trump for at least a
couple more years
because the truth is that this isn't
even close to the first unacceptable
thing that donald trump has done or said
so the idea that only now does theresa
may find donald trump's actions
condemnable
that's laughable she's preparing to no
longer be the prime minister
of britain it's a red flag that we're
only now hearing this from her for the
first time and what it says to me is
that more than likely
there are many world leaders who are
just biting their tongues
because they would have to deal with the
political repercussions of saying
this guy is disgusting we condemn what
donald trump has said we condemn what
donald trump has done so i hope
that more and more world leaders will
say what's on their minds
it needs to be made clear that only
american trumpists see this as normal
okay the american left
most american moderates obviously don't
see what's going on as normal but
it's important and it would be useful to
make clear
that most of the world sees what's going
on is outrageous this is not
what the office of the american
presidency should be or should stand for
so
no real pat on the back for uh theresa
may from me
certainly none for all of the other
world leaders who are keeping quiet
let's hear them say what they really
think and then let's have to deal with
the repercussions of that
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter deepakman follow me there follow
me on twitter
you can also follow the david pakman
show on twitter at david pakman show for
all the latest
news and content from the show daily
today's sponsor is skillshare and i'm
excited to tell you that
everybody in our audience is getting two
entire months of free access to
skillshare
when you click the link underneath this
video skillshare is the site that offers
over
25 000 online courses on almost any
topic
you can imagine cooking meditation
photography
video editing photoshop managing a small
business
almost an endless list and whether
you're trying to get
ahead in your career maybe you want to
learn new skills
that will make you better at your job
you might just be exploring a new hobby
and you're trying to find new ways to be
creative in your personal time
skillshare is the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn
i really enjoyed the class on more
advanced
video editing techniques because it's
something i've been wanting to improve
at but have been
very busy hosting the david pakman show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by skillshare
after those two months
if you want to keep your subscription
skillshare super affordable at less than
10 bucks a month
get better at whatever it is that you're
passionate about or discover something
brand new
that you didn't even know that you would
love and join skillshare's
other 7 million users by clicking the
link underneath this video